لم تكن اكثر توقعات الاعلاميين الافغان
تشائما لتصف وضع الاعلام الافغاني الان
بعد النحو 18 شهرا من سيطره حركه طالبان
التامه على البلاد بدل مشهد الاعلامي
الافغاني رمزا من رموز الماضي اما الحاضر
فصادم العشرات من الاعلاميين توقفوا عن
ممارسه عملهم وغادروا البلاد او يحاولون
المغادره فيما وسائل الاعلام تبحث عن طوق
نجاته
قريش
المتحده بدعم الاعلام في افغانستان وتلعب
دورا فعالا في اعاده الصحفيين الذين
غادروا البلاد مسرور لطفي اعلامي افغاني
يقول انه هروب الصحفيين من البلد واغلاق
وسائل الاعلام اظهر الاتجاه الهبوطيه
السريع للاعلام مضيفا ان المشاكل الماليه
وقله الوصول الى المعلومات وقله التنوع في
البرامج المشاكل ما زالت قائمه
كامري
اجتماعات مختلفه وطالبان تقول لنا انها
بصددي وضع
برامج وس
ائل الارجو
ان تقوم بتنفيذ برامج دعمها باسرع وقت
ممكن
تعال لنا الاتحاد الوطني للصحفيين الافغان
ان ما لا يقل عن 50079 وسيله اعلاميه كانت
تعمل في البلد وانخفض عددها عام 2022 الى
192 من فذن اعلاميا وان 70% من الاعلاميين
وثلاثين في المئه من الاعلاميات فقدوا
وظائفهم يقولوا بيانو الاتحاد الوطني
للصحفيين الافغان في اوائل عام 2022 كانت
خطاباته بعض المسؤولين من طالبان وعدده
حول الاعتراف بقانون الاعلام وتنفيذي ولكن
لم يشهد المجتمع الاعلامي الافغاني ان
يتقدم ملحوظ في مجال القوانين الاعلاميه
عبد الله ناذر العربيه